15 days ago at the Wednesday audience I
was saying goodbye to people
I arrived at a lady if you may know she
was basically 50 years old just like me
yeah
[Music]
I agreed the lady
says bless my baby it's a dog
I didn't have patience
said ma'am so many children are hungry I
love that thank you papa Francesco that
is a beautiful thing to say he's
obviously right on the point here I
don't mean to disparage people with dogs
I'm not totally a dog person or a cat
person I'm more of a people person but I
know people love their dogs and it's
good to love your dogs you know how to
cut to the core of me Baxter but you've
got to love your dogs in a way that is
appropriate to a dog